- DOCTOR FORREST, DIAL 118,
PLEASE.
DR. FORREST, PLEASE DIAL 1-1-8.
- [sighs]
DON?
- YES, I'M HERE.
- PROMISE YOU'LL NEVER
FORGET ABOUT ME.
- YES.
OF COURSE.
- PROMISE ME YOU'LL TAKE CARE
OF OUR LITTLE GIRL.
AND LOVE HER.
- YES, WITH ALL MY HEART.
- PROMISE ME YOU'LL STAY STRONG
FOR HER.
- YES, YES.
I PROMISE.
- AND PROMISE ME YOU'LL NEVER
SLEEP WITH ANOTHER WOMAN.
- [clicking]
I HEAR YOU.
- PROMISE ME YOU'LL TAKE CARE
OF MR. BIG FLUFFY TAIL?
- YES.
YES, YES, YES, DONE.
THAT CAT WILL BE
THE MOST LOVED CAT IN THE WORLD.
- AND THAT YOU WON'T LOOK
AT PORN.
- AHH.
- HUH?
- [speaking gibberish]
- IS THAT YES?
- CHECKY, CHECKY, CHECKY,
CHECKY, CHICKETY, CHICKETY,
CHICKETY CHECK.
- NO PORNOGRAPHY.
- BUSTER BROWN SAYS WHAT?
- IS THAT A YES?
- YO BETTER BELIEVE
I HEARD WHAT YOU SAID, GIRL.
- YOU LOVE ME, RIGHT?
- YES, I LOVE YOU.
YES.
- AND WE'RE SOUL MATES, RIGHT?
- YES.
- SO YOU WILL NEVER, EVER,
EVER THINK OF SOMEONE ELSE
WHILE MASTURBATING, RIGHT?
- [as robot]
MESSAGE RECEIVED.
- I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
IS THAT A YES?
- YO COMPRENDE.
- IS THAT A PROMISE?
- [goofy voice]
YOUR REQUEST HAS BEEN FILED.
- SAY YOU PROMISE.
- FORGET ABOUT, HUH?
HUH?
- I NEED TO HEAR YOU SAY IT.
- IT.
- I--NO, SAY, "I PRO--
I PROMISE."
- YOU PROMISE.
- YOU--YOU PROMISE.
SAY IT.
- OKAY, "I PROMISE."
- NO AIR QUOTES.
- ♪ PROMISES ARE THINGS
THAT MOTHERS-- ♪
- SAY IT, SAY IT!
- I PROMISE, I PROMISE.
- WHAT ARE YOU PROMISING?
- I PROMISE WHAT YOU SAID.
- FINE, FORGET IT.
- YES.
I MEAN, OKAY.
- WILL YOU AT LEAST PROMISE
TO GO SEE MY MOM EVERY DAY?
- SO ZERO PORNOGRAPHY?
DONE.
I LIKE THAT.
NURSE?
FIX MY WIFE!
[crying]
DON'T TOUCH ME RIGHT NOW.
I'M JUST--
IT'S NOT--NOT ALL ABOUT YOU.